vivre c'est le titre du film présenté à
cannes un titre événement parce qu'il
s'agit d'un film chinois de 200 gimme
parce que ce film présenté en
compétition n'a pas obtenu le visa de
censure de pékin cannes on l'a vu avec
la bosnie dimanche
on le voit aujourd'hui avec les
atteintes aux droits de l'homme cannes
ce n'est pas seulement des histoires
d'amour l'école cornu langlois bruno
girodon il ne viendra pas ce réalisateur
retenu en chine
mais ces deux acteurs vont se battre
pour son film vivre gong li vient
régulièrement à cannes depuis sorgho
rouge en 1988 elle jouait déjà avec
guillou dans adieu ma concubine puisque
michalik
s'ils arrivent à la carte moi aussi
j'attends d'en vivre ils sont un couple
qui traverse 40 tant d'événements
extraordinaires de leur pays de la
prospérité insouciante à la révolution
culturelle et une femme sont assez
ordinaire de la chine
dans son côté ordinaire je crois que
c'est là qu'on retrouve le côté
grandiose un peu gauche à la limite du
grotesque gaillou donne un côté comique
à cette tragédie
acte i way you lie de joie gianni mina a
expliqué aux acteurs par exemple antique
qui a été prisonnier et il sort de la
prison
est ce que vous pensez qu'il a il a
envie de parler des choses vraiment
difficile de la prison plutôt il nous a
raconté des histoires faisait moins
drôle qu'il a eu avec les embryons ue
dans les moeurs
il est question aussi d'épreuves
douloureuses de passion du jeu de
théâtre d'ombrés mais pourquoi le
talentueux réalisateur cette fresque
poignante n'at-il pu sortir de son pays
liviu préfère se voiler la face que de
répondre et gong li aimerait bien tout
d'un coup voire une tasse de thé au
jasmin ce soir aux marches du palais
l'absent était omniprésent